and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 154 I
believe it's 154 we're trying something
new today we don't have notes in front
of us we have questions we're winging it
in front of us winging it yes and so
what we did is we wanted to turn to our
patreon supporters and ask you if you
had specific questions for us so I
reached out to you all this morning and
we're gonna we're gonna call this
episode minimal because we're gonna
answer questions about minimalism I
asked if our patreon supporters had
questions for the minimalist and I had a
question please keep it to sentences or
less what I asked them I don't ask you
to do the same thing Ryan
what does winging it mean I mean I know
what it means but where does that idiom
come from swinging it yeah yeah like
someone comment on the video below where
that idiom came from way yes where if
you're winging it what does that mean
exactly like we know what it means we
just don't know where it came from
yeah yeah but why does it mean what does
it mean what's the original media
meaning it's got it has to do something
with Lake what's the etymology of the
words or something yeah I don't know
anyway shout out to the Wright brothers
Dayton Ohio we raised all right our
first question is from Irina who did not
listen to the two sentences or less I
have a company which right now doesn't
produce enough money in order for me to
save up I make enough to live pay my
rent and buy food and pay bills I also
have a youtube channel that sometimes
brings some money I'm not sure whether
the focus more on YouTube so that I can
create another stream of income or try
to find another stream of income what
would you do
okay so so Ryan I think if you're trying
to do something creative I would never
look at it as a stream of income yeah I
mean yes like looking at Irene arena
Irene arena looking at Irina's question
you know she's got these talons
but trying to his talons talent his
talent and trying to find one of these
talents to drive an income from or he or
a passion what's called a passion not a
talent but like so she's passionate
about something I totally agree like
looking specifically to make money off
of a passion is not the best approach in
my opinion I thought Seth Godin did a
podcast recently he was he was talking
about sequence how sequence is important
and you know like if you have a big
spaghetti dinner in front of you you
don't take like a wet nap and wipe your
mouth before you eat the spaghetti
dinner yes that's a great analogy you
wait until you've got the spaghetti all
over you're so smart quoting Seth Godin
Shawn edited out the part of Seth Cohen
I have this original thought about
spaghetti that's a brilliant analogy
exactly what that means
in this case to forget the spaghetti is
the creativity right and so express
yourself creatively now you may or may
not be able to make a full time or even
part-time income from that creativity
but you might be able to make a
difference in the world with that
creativity yeah and eventually if you
help enough people solve enough problems
then money will follow people pay money
for things this is how capitalism works
is they pay money for solutions to what
they perceive to be a problem yes if you
add value to people's lives they will go
out of their way to support you like
whether it's I mean when I think about
when we first started the minimalists I
mean what do we make that first year
like twenty eight thousand bucks
I made $23,000 I soon we made this yes
yeah we did
and it's just crazy how you know people
didn't necessarily support us monetarily
like oh you know that you guys came out
with a book I'm gonna buy you know a
million copies of your book but but
people I mean some people did do that
but other people also went out of their
way to offer us a place to stay while we
were on tour take us out for a meal so I
mean even though it wasn't like this
direct stream of income from those those
examples bringing us out to a meal of
sand in our house people still go out of
their way to add value so irena really
what you've got to do is figure out ways
that you can add more value and then
once you do that
people will go out of the way to support
you I mean you could do something as
simple as well we have a patreon and
Josh and I go way out of our way to add
as much value as we can to those
subscribers and Irina you could do the
same exact thing I mean if you're if
you're looking to expand your your
revenue streams there's a million
different ways to do it you just got to
find a way that is going to work best
for you and your audience and and you
know just put it out there and if you're
looking to be more financially secure in
the short term do something that's going
to make you money if there's if there's
if money is an outcome for you I totally
get that it's always gonna be part of
the recipe absolutely and I don't want
to deny like well don't ever worry about
money that's not what I'm saying here it
can't be the primary driver for your
creative outlets because you're going to
force a quality and creativity because
you're trying to conform to a particular
ideology or you're trying to please
everyone yeah and so if you need to make
money in the short term to pay off debt
to save up some money then go drive a
Luber or lyft go find a way to get a
side hustle yeah our friend Chris
Guillebeau has a great podcast called
side hustle and he has a book called
side hustle as well and he talks about
people who set up these side hustles
that may or may not become their
full-time muscles their full-time
incomes but it's enough to supplement
what their regular income is so yeah I
would definitely recommend that yeah
definitely I mean just to reiterate what
I was saying at the beginning when you
take a passion and you challenge
yourself I shouldn't say challenge
yourself you put pressure on yourself to
make money off of that passion it is a
very that's a very good way to kill a
passion a lot of yeah go back to episode
123 we did a podcast with with our good
friend Paul from Canyon City yeah and we
talked about hobbies and one thing he
did he signed this big like record
contract and he was making it was
finally making a full-time living off of
music oh by the way he's one of the most
talented musicians I've ever met yeah
and he signed this contract he was
finally making a full-time living off of
music yeah except it wasn't the music
that he wanted to make and it was just
so crushing for him yeah and so one of
the ways to kill your passion is to try
to make an ink
come off and make that your primary
driver and watch your watch your passion
just die on the vine
yeah yeah I I I'm so glad that we have
not forced ourselves into doing that
because if we I mean if we did take on
projects that we just felt like our
audience was going to buy or you know
what whatever instead of doing it for
ourselves what we were really passionate
about we might find ourselves in the
same situation that Paul was in I mean
we could do the declutter the minimalist
decluttering God guide to decluttering
here's 67 separate clutter at your home
or whatever yeah and and and that's just
not appealing to us right because we
like to talk about the purpose and the
why behind what we're doing the house
stuff is important and you have to
certainly inject it in there we share
our a recipe that's our how and you can
figure out what works well for you
Connor asks what's one long term goal
slash ambition you want to realize in
the next year in the net within the next
365 days yeah maybe but let's just say
by the end of 2019 okay oh man um well
we got to get this other documentary out
yeah that's the big one for me right now
like to me so Ryan and I for those of
you aren't aware of our sort of strategy
if you want to call it that it's or it's
it's maybe it's anti strategy in a way
because we tend to take on one big
project at a time yeah and that usually
is like one per calendar year and that
shifts and in fact this one is shifting
right now because we finished this
documentary the second documentary and
we got the first cut and we're like wow
this is good and that's the problem
it's good we didn't want it to be good
in fact there were parts of it that were
great but we want it to be outstanding
we want it to be the best we can do
given the resources we have and so we
had to go back and say alright we're
actually during the month of October
we're reshooting certain segments of the
documentary in different locations so
that we can look ourselves in the mirror
and say you know what this is the best I
could do it's never going to be perfect
so I never have a goal or objective of
perfection because I'm always gonna
that's the expectation part yeah it says
so instead of us having these these
crazy expectations we just have really
high
standards for anything that we create
yeah and the next thing we were working
on we can't talk about yet not yet but
we oh this is an anxiety I am I'm just
drying right now it probably ought to
talk about it early 2019 so our next big
project is something different from this
this second documentary and talk about
not allowing money to be a primary
driver we signed a deal I won't tell you
what kind of deal it's a storage
container business yeah but they're tiny
containers so you have to run a bunch of
and they cost just as much as regular
can writers know the thing is like we
had we had the small sort of bidding war
on this next project that we want to
work on and if money was the primary
driver we actually wouldn't have done
the deal that we do because there were
other opportunities for us to make a
whole lot more money off of this project
off of this project but it wasn't the
right fit because what we believe in is
getting our creativity out there and a
one partner yeah someone who like
believes in us I mean when I think about
when we were looking for someone to
represent us for PR I mean I talked like
20 different people and the reason why
we ended up going with Sarah maniaci was
because she was bought into us I mean
she was she was actually it wasn't like
okay guys if you want to get your book
out here's what I'm gonna do for you I
mean she was excited to work with us
excited to help us promote our book and
to help us with our tour and and that's
that's what we look for with anyone that
we bring on the team whether it's you
know PR whether it's a deal that we're
talking about right now the deal we're
talking about or Jordan or Sean
we're just Jess yeah we want Jeff Dave
we might as well name them all now
but yeah anyone that we work with money
is definitely a factor like you said
it's always going to be a factor it has
to play into it but that is not the
number one driver right it's going to be
an ingredient in the recipe or maybe
even better analogy it's going money
will be a a passenger in the vehicle but
you don't want to let it drive
I mean if that was the case dude we we
could like sell out and do
advertisements on this podcast yeah but
not just any like retire there's
probably a way we could do advertising
on this podcast of what align with our
values but but if money was a primary
driver we would just do pre-roll mid
roll after roll and just like cram in 15
commercials about a bunch of stuff we
don't care about we don't use whatever
and just cram it in cram it in and and
act like we were excited about it till
Dru asks I just finished paying off my
debt and say and saving for an emergency
I'm saving for an emergency funnies
congratulations
like yeah that is awesome I know I am
looking to move somewhere closer to work
is it bad to spend a bit more for an
apartment that has an extra bedroom that
I want for a home office or is it
wasteful when I'm single but would still
be saving 30 percent of my income even
with the extra room that it there's not
a black or white answer to that right
yeah I mean there are there are times
when yes you should save the money it
depends on what your what you're saving
for I mean if I was in his situation I
want to ask myself what is it that I'm
actually saving for yeah what does my
outcome here yeah because maybe maybe
the outcome is I want to be more
productive and this office is gonna help
me do I think about our friend Rob Bell
one thing he did when he was living in
Grand Rapids and he was trying to
protect his time for creating because he
was managing this large organization he
was he was working at a church and the
weird thing about becoming the creative
person at church you're also the manager
and so like you're there people are
dragging you to all these meetings and
stuff and he found himself being like he
was he was losing his time to create
when we were we were sitting down with
the The Today Show yesterday when they
came out here to talk with us one of the
things you talked about with the gal Jo
who was who was interviewing us is
protecting your mornings and your what
you really time I was protecting this
creative time or this time for health or
whatever it might be and for Rob what he
did is he rented a like just a crappy
office with just a desk and a chair in
it downtown away from home away from his
his office at work and it was just this
office it was solely for creating and he
said I would go there and spend two to
four hours a day
and as long as I was creating for at
least a couple hours a day then it was
worth it to me even though I had to
spend you know a few hundred dollars a
month in order to do that so if your
outcome is creativity drew then maybe it
makes sense for that extra money but is
that creativity worth the worth the
money you're giving up that you could
spend on something else is there
something greater than that and also
let's not fool ourselves and think we
have to have the perfect setup in order
to be creative right I think of Stephen
King and he wrote I think his first
couple books in his laundry room and
because he didn't have an office so he's
just hanging out in his laundry room
right and and I think of some of the
most creative times in my life have been
with constraints so I didn't have the
perfect writing area I had this crappy
Ikea desk and a crappy chair and was
facing a brick wall not looking out a
window there was nothing pristine I was
in Dayton Ohio in this tiny little
apartment and I was facing a wall in a
writing mm-hm
and it didn't matter what the I didn't
have to have the perfect office with the
potted plant and everything else
creating is creating regardless of your
location yeah I think for me the most
minimal maximum for you pal I'm not sure
the most important thing for me is to
just have as little distractions as
possible yes so like right now I just
sit on my sofa and I write when I when I
do right or I'll sit on the floor Indian
style and tilt my computer up a little
bit you know so I can see it and just
write on the floor for me it's not about
the atmosphere as much as it is well I
mean it is the atmosphere because you
can clutter the atmosphere but it's not
about like being in these having these
certain parameters being in this certain
space it's more about clearing as much
as many distractions out of the way as
possible when I go to write so if the
solution for for him for Brett Brent
drew for Drew sorry drew is so so for
drew for you man if having this office
is the best way for you to create
distraction-free
then go for it man but you know what
drew like you're the only one that knows
what what is gonna be best for you the
other thing too is you're saving 30
percent of your income that's huge what
is what is Ramsey usually recommend 25%
listen saving so so one thing that he
writes in his book smart money smart
kids that and I think this is applicable
to adults especially but you teach your
kids when they're young and we're
starting something like this with Ellen
f he's finally starting to grasp the
concept of money and then like the dirty
pieces of paper in my pocket or actually
worth something and you have to earn
those those dirty pieces of paper and so
he has like three envelopes or three
buckets basically you have a savings
envelope a giving envelope and a
spending envelope for kids and I think
the same the same thing is true so in
terms of saving for your future he tends
to recommend 20% of your income yeah so
saving 30% I mean drew you're ten
percent of what you know Dave Ramsey
recommends but I know like some people
in the fire community finance I don't
know what the acronym is I don't know
put in the notes of pot cash on but uh
the the fire community they part of a
documentary they they've got coming out
we'll put a link to they'd like a
Kickstarter it's about all you have to
be great to put a link to that in the in
the show notes yeah yeah so you and I
sat down we did this interview for the
fire community and it's really about
it's a financial independence retire
early yes that's what it is there you go
and and in that community is you know
made up of a bunch of different types of
people who are interested in and no
longer letting money being the the the
driver of all the discontent in our
lives
yeah and they like some of those guys in
the community some of those guys and
gals they will save upwards of 50
percent of their of their income but see
they have different goals like drew what
are your goals man like the people in
the fire community they are trying to
get financial dependence and retire
early as early as possible so drew of
that to your goal then maybe you do give
up that office to save a little bit more
each month but if your goal is to not
run you know just retire you know 55 65
you know whenever whenever a normal
retirement age is then then ya get get
the extra bedroom and create the perfect
situation for you to create and I think
I think that's that's a really good
point because if our goal was to make
money with this podcast we like you said
we would have put advertising our
advertisements on it we actually spend
money to make this podcast which seems
counter and
right because we rent this studio space
here we pay for all the equipment we
don't do any ads we pay podcast Sean we
pay Jordan Joe no mo Geronimo is the
YouTube consensus on his new nickname
and in what the reason we're doing this
those because the message we believe in
allows us to consistently share that
message via this vehicle that is
different from the other vehicles that
we use whether it's our books whether it
is our writing whether it is our film or
documentary whatever it is like we
actually spend money to put this podcast
out there every month thankfully our
patreon supporters help help supplement
that but yeah I was I was just getting
ready to mention the man like thank God
for them there they really help out with
a lot of this I think once we get the
three thousand patreon supporters then
we'll have enough to break even a little
very happy we'll still be happy okay but
yeah so if you do want to support us up
say this only once there in this podcast
it's just the minimalists comm slash
support we do a bonus podcast every week
as well it's called the the minimalist
private podcast we we do a post script
episode we also do ask the minimal s
anything episodes and live streams every
month over there on patreon silvio asks
i have a five month old son and so it's
been five months since myself and my
wife have had a good night's sleep
oh man he's gonna bite but about ten
years for me but anyway ten-year-old son
no I just sleep like garbage yeah we'll
talk about that in a second I think I
think it's a question is this would be a
good time to talk about it Josh how has
having a child change your idea or
practices as a minimalist so let me just
say this Ella is not a special-needs
child she is a special once child she
has very special once and she she when
she was really young special one I was
gonna say something really when you
talking about sitting cross-legged on
the couch yeah you know press like it on
the floor oh you--oh are you afraid that
that's cultural appropriation and if so
what does your sister think about I'm
gonna be honest I don't believe in
cultural appropriation your sister
doesn't get mad about no no she does
occur echt you or anything she does okay
that's good so anyway out thankfully so
during Ella's waking hours so not
thankfully for this when L was really
young especially before she turned 3 man
she was trying out for al Qaeda they're
hurting for members men well I mean she
clearly was top of the class
and but but thankfully she sleeps like a
rock man she sleeps 11 or 12 hours a
night oh my god I'm so jealous yeah and
me too
like a good tire just thinking about her
sleeping for 12 hours a night it's
unbelievable but the rest of that she
wakes up and she's an instant tornado
and I'm like what's that has Manian
devil yeah that's pretty much lol
throughout the entire day and then all
of a sudden she just crashes at night so
it works out well for her but that's not
answering Sylvia's question how having a
child change your idea or practices as a
minimalist well I mean I realized that
minimalism I knew this before but it
became more of a practice now minimalism
is not about deprivation you and I say
that all the time but I remember at
first like I kind of wanted yeah well
you know kids don't really need anything
any toys they were happy with whatever
they have and I was really just
projecting my own childhood onto her
like cuz I didn't have many toys or the
ones I did were crappy although in my
neighborhood I had more toys anyone else
that's how I made all the friends dude
you had a Sega Genesis man yeah that's
how I made literally all the friends in
there because they don't play Sega
because you're gonna stick a jet we're
on food stamps that I had and I was rich
oh yeah anyway a mineral yes man we were
good at Oh Jim and I were patched back
in after that commercial break yes I
mean how's minimalism changed or how's
having a child changed my idea of
simplicity or minimalism I've realized
that minimalism is not about deprivation
I knew that in theory but now I know it
in practice because I don't want to
deprive Ella of having the things that
she wants now the average child has 300
toys but plays with only 12 daily Wow
that tells me something here that is a
metaphor for our own lives because the
average adult has 300 thousand items and
plays with you know 12,000 daily I don't
know what that number is but like it's
not even that right and and and so we
just tend to accumulate more once we get
older and we're allowed to accumulate
more and so Ella has toys I take L to
the toy store but I also instill the
practice of contributing to her as well
so we go to the goodwill once a month
and we let go of some stuff that she's
no longer playing with and then she
doesn't realize like I'm just getting
rid of this stuff so it's not the me
explaining the theory of contribution to
her because she's not gonna understand
that she's five but what she does
understand is hey I'm not playing with
this anymore I can see another kid
playing with it and I understand that I
don't need this anymore and if I get rid
of this I can bring new toys into my
life that I will like that I will enjoy
isn't it crazy like how kids love to
help man like whether it's like you know
with with anything they just love to
help but especially with contribution I
could see where that would be exciting
for Ella or at least being able to
understand like Oh like I'm gonna give
this to another kid gonna hit the garage
door button they want to lay everything
like they want to help with everything
and the same is true with contribution
and so the thing that I've learned is
yes ello does great with a box of toys
but if she had ten boxes of toys or a
hundred boxes of toys she's not gonna be
ten times or a hundred times happier in
fact especially someone like Ella who
has well it's called SPD since
reprocessing disorder and she just gets
overstimulated by sensory items
especially physical items and it's loud
loud sounds and bright lights her first
words were mine eyes mine eye her first
words yeah so the the the clutter with
her is actually it it like with me it
stresses her out and so we made sure
that you know she has just the
appropriate amount of toys and if she
stops playing with something then she's
not I don't donate it she donates it so
there's someone who's gonna ask what is
the appropriate amount what's 12 daily
no I and I'm not actually asking for a
number what not the reason why I bring
that up is because the number is the
appropriate amount there isn't a number
yeah you can spread across the board
with every child and say this is the
appropriate amount yeah well I did a
whole video on this with Ella actually
on our YouTube channel it's we did one
of the living room conversations Sean I
think put a link to that in the show
notes we talked about how many toys kids
should have and I had outlet talk about
she was playing her trumpet on the video
as well and so we just we were playing
like firetruck and Hospital on the the
the she likes really gory things which
is disturbing like she's like we went to
go like buy some like brothers called
playmate the the sort of playsets that
you put together is that playmate I
think something like that anyway we went
and bought and she was like going I want
the the surgery room and I'm like okay
yeah she wants to be a doctor she's like
I want a serial killer what I want the
morgue next question is from Connor this
is a different Connor howdy this is kind
of with a no the previous Connor was
Connor with an A mmm Connor asks how do
you find happiness when your stress this
is from Connor boy man happiness is not
the point yeah it's a misnomer I feel
like because I mean it's written in the
Constitution or any like everyone has
the right to pursue happiness suit of
happiness not the right to happiness
yeah it's uh got it that the pursuit of
happiness
can be I don't know it can be a
deflating goal because like because I
feel like in the corporate world I was
continuously chasing happiness sure and
I would get a new car or I go on a
vacation or you know I'd buy you know
I'd upgrade my my computer or whatever
it is upgrade my TV I was kind of
chasing that happiness but the more I
chased it the further away I got from it
yeah
so the for me when I'm stressed it's not
about how can I be happy because well
first off stress is important like I
don't want to live a stress-free life no
I mean that sounds like death almost
yeah like I want a little bit of
friction I want to have a I want to have
the ability to have a little bit of
stress because the someone told me in
the corporate world one time there cuz I
was complaining about how stressed out I
was and they were like you know Ryan
little stress is good for you and I
agree with that I did not have just a
little bit of stress though when we were
when we were in those jobs but but I do
agree with the statement that a little
bit of stress is good because stress is
an indicator that something is wrong
your body is telling you hey you need to
do something different you have to take
a different approach with whatever it is
that you're doing yeah there's good
stress and bad stress you you you you
exercise five six days a week
of course I do I mean you lift oh my god
you care if I put those guns away
Jordan do not put that in the video out
to the YouTube audience oh there's gonna
be lightning bolts coming off of your
biceps actually what you need to do is
like CGI like Arnold Schwarzenegger arms
yes yeah do we have any um CGI programs
no no I don't even know what that means
you know what CGI means we wouldn't have
to be here man he could CG is in we
could do Holograms no I think about it
alright I'm guessing so yeah so so where
was I going I work out yeah you work in
and that's a good kind of stress you you
had you put enough stress on your body
that you grow so there's a certain
amount of stress that you grow if you
were to work out seven hours a day
your your body's gonna break down you're
going to atrophy so there is it's a
bell-curve that's a good analogy
and then look as you grow you can put
more of the good kind of stress on you
as opposed to that now physiologically
and psychologically quite often your
body does not know the difference
between good stress and bad stress
psychologically you you can you can
parse it out right but but the physical
physiology of stress is going to be the
same even good stress in bachelors that
you even have to be careful with the
good stresses and your life's not to get
too much use the word friction though
you want some friction in your life and
you need enough friction in order to to
create traction in your life because if
you don't you think about we were
driving on the roads in Montana and it's
so icy there's no traction at all
because there's no friction right it's
frictionless it's black ice and you're
going to I mean literally you you
someone ran you off the road because
they hit a patch of black ice and your
car flipped because they didn't have
enough friction that created the
traction to propel you forward and so
yeah I think I think keep that in mind
so happiness is often a fruitless
pursuit and in fact we mentioned Chris
Gila but once we did a podcast with him
he had a book come out that was called
so you just mentioned the constitution
right the everyone has the right to the
pursuit of happiness
yes his book is called the happiness of
pursuit oh yeah and so so think about
that the real happiness the real
contentment for me comes from the work
or the creativity the the production the
passion itself the pursuit quite all in
fact think about that quite often we
pursue these things thinking it's going
to make us happy one day but then you
get there and you feel empty well why is
that because you thought the outcome is
what was going to make you happy it's
not the outcome that's gonna make you
happy
it is the pursuit its enjoying the
pursuit it's become platitudinous this
point where you're like okay yeah if you
enjoy the pursuit enjoy the journey yeah
that that's true but really find ways to
do something that you do enjoy it's the
reason writing is so appealing to me
like
I in fact I there's this old platitude
that actually doesn't make any sense to
me personally writers don't enjoy
writing they enjoy having written yeah
I'm the exact opposite because when I
when I write there's a good chunk of the
time 10 to 20 percent of the time where
I get into this like euphoric state when
everything is firing on all cylinders
but it takes half the time I want to put
my head through a wall the other 30% of
the time it's like yeah this is going
pretty well I feel good about sentence
structure and all of a sudden it starts
clicking clicking I'm getting that flow
state was what some people call it and
as that happens I like there's there's
no better feeling other than sex and and
and like you just get going and going
that is the pursuit having the thing
written I can go back and look at the
novel that I wrote and like cringe at
parts of it there parts of it I could
absolutely say wow I don't know how I
wrote that beautiful there are other
parts where I'm like as the decade fades
was a good book considering I wrote a
lot of it in my mid-20s over a decade
ago yeah I'm trying to think of so if I
do when I stress out too much I will
well I'll give you an example we were
heading to the airport about a week ago
Mariah and I were and we got into the
car we needed to be to the airport in
about 45 minutes we got into the uber
and they were drivers like alright we'll
be there about an hour and I was like oh
man like knowing that we were gonna cut
it really really close to going to the
airport but then of course you know as
we're driving like I'm going through
what what Dan Harris talked about in our
documentary with okay I know that I need
to stress a little bit because we do
have to be on time at the airport or as
on time as possible sure I do want to
you know let the driver know like hey
not not your problem but if you could
help us out or you know we're trying to
get there as soon as possible without
being a jerk yeah I may I'll make sure
give you a big tip but just you know
just I just wanted to you know see if
you would be willing to you know kind of
pay a little bit extra attention and you
know whatever drive a little faster
whatever right
he was totally amicable
um but even on the way to the airport
though like he was doing everything he
could I was still like just stressing
out a lot he put on some jazz music yeah
I had no idea how soothing jazz music
was it was like totally change your
state right I wholly changed my saving
fascicle will do the same thing you knew
what really does it for me
sigur rós yeah I can see that I have
this Pandora playlist in fact I pay for
Pandora every month because in the
mornings I like to just put on my
cigarette list and it recommends all the
songs as well it calms my and it le was
like it's soft soothing music so so uh
with with this question how do I be
happy when I stress that I think the
question needs to be reframed a little
bit yes how can I avoid the really bad
stress in my life yeah so or how can I
avoid over stressing and that's where I
would start with this question to do
that yes do things like listening that
you listen to some jazz listen to some
cigarettes
meditate meditation is such this morning
I was doing I was flipping out this
morning cause like I just had a really
bad night of sleep I just you know a
bunch of little stupid thing you know
spilt my cup of coffee
you know whatever just a bunch of little
stupid things going on and because of
the lack of sleep I just like wanted to
put my fist through a wall but I like
just sat on the couch for like five
minutes just did some breathing like in
through the nose out through the mouth
and I like I'll start counting like you
know for four seconds in four seconds
out
but even you know after a minute of
doing that I forget to count and I just
you know start relaxing a little bit so
you know any little things that you can
do like that to help you to help curb
the stress but you know approaching that
question with how can i how can I stop
the stress and then insert happiness
that's just to me that's very poor
expectation yeah definitely that
actually bridges right into the next
question here Kenneth asks what do you
wish you had done earlier in your
process to minimize quicker / become
happier quicker
here's the thing guys happiness is the
wrong pursuit happiness is ephemeral and
if you're always chasing ephemeral
things then you're always going to feel
the pang of discontent tweet that
podcast Sean and and so the thing that
I'll add on top of that the right
pursuit is a more meaningful life and so
instead of pursuing happiness pursue
what a meaningful life means for you not
the meaning of life that's another
difficult question I saw a bunch of
people asked us that question on Twitter
today for the lightning round I've got a
couple Twitter questions it's several
what's the purpose of life what's the
meaning of life I don't know I'll start
all divulge it or digress into a
nihilistic sort of rant if you ask me
that
I mean I'll say the growth and
contribution is ultimately the meaning
of life I think there's no point of life
and it's actually freeing for me to
realize that there isn't a point to any
of this I mean so the it depends what we
mean by point right and so maybe there
are better questions is the the the
meaning of what's the meaning of life is
not a great question how do I become
happier all the time
bad question and and the better question
is what does a meaningful life look like
to you now for me that means my values
I'm really clear on what my values are
and my actions align with what those
values are and whenever I slip whenever
I fall off the path then all of a sudden
I realize that discontent is coming from
not because all of a sudden I'm not
happy but because my values are are not
being met in a way so Kenneth with your
question here man if I could if Josh and
I could give you a pill right now we'll
send you a pill in the mail it'll make
you as happy as you've ever been
they do have post for that mm-hmm it's
called MDMA and then you take the MDMA
again the next day and then you take it
the third day and then you take it the
fourth day and then you take it the
fifth day um that you it will start to
become your new norm mm-hmm so I guess
maybe a better way said the MDMA example
is not that's not my best no I think
it's an example because there's a crash
after you take him there at there
absolutely is great so talk about that
because people go to Burning Man
and they take in DMA for two or three
days and all of a sudden they're like
they're miserable for several days
that's a perfect analogy yeah oh yeah
yeah I guess yeah and that in that sense
it is the other thing I was gonna say
too though is so Kenneth even if you
know Josh and I could flip a switch
right now and make you wake up every
morning as static that it that's Manik
yes and Manik people like at their you
know at the extreme version of it like
people who are truly truly manic like
happy and excited about life well there
are a lot of the times they are out in
the street directing traffic and it
haven't been asked to direct traffic
right exactly like Kenneth you don't
want to be in the street directing
traffic because because that person who
is who is extremely manic they true
they're in the street they're happy
about life and they're like oh I can
help traffic flow better I'm just gonna
go take initiative and do this yeah a
truly a truly happy person is when I say
truly happy uh an extremely happy person
would be manic and manic at its terminus
is is is a mental illness yeah
absolutely I mean my father was
manic-depressive and he had those fits
were where he I mean he was also
schizophrenic so he he had full long
happy conversations with people who did
not exist in the real world and and and
and yeah you don't want to be there but
what does a meaningful life look like to
you what are your values go back and
listen to our values podcast episode
it's episode 69 and if you want to get
really clear on your values my partner
in a Rebecca and I we go through our
values all the time and she has like a
little one-page worksheet based on what
we go through it's minimal wellness calm
slash values I felt like we really
wasted episode 69 on the episode values
hey what we did where did the sex
episode that was with with that
should've been exit anyway well sure way
to 160
there was there there's one more thing I
want to add okay
and maybe maybe you said this and I
missed it Milburn but if you pursue a
meaningful life if your short term
actions are aligning with those long
term values and beliefs the beautiful
thing is is you do have happiness as a
by-product it is not you're not gonna
wake up every single morning and you
know ride to work on a unicorn going
down Rainbow Road but but you will you
will find more meaning to your life and
when you when you are able to do things
that that that are good for yourself
whether it's health or whether it's
bringing in good relationships or
whether it's contributing beyond
yourself after you after you do those
things that's when that's when I feel
happy is when I when I have those
actions when I take those actions that
are in alignment with those those core
values but you're in the key there is
that wasn't the ideal outcome it was the
byproduct itself absolutely happiness
yeah yeah I mean well and there isn't
even a goal for me like I I don't want
there to be a goal I want there to be a
direction and and I think that that
that's the that's the important thing is
is what is my direction my direction is
to live a more meaningful life to grow
in that direction and yes I'll be
happier more on the aggregate when I'm
living a meaningful life there will
there's I could do a whole bunch of
really stupid irresponsible stuff and be
happy in the moment right
but eventually you're like why did I do
that
yeah and and and longer-term the
aggregate happiness is gonna be much
less when when you do that our next
question is from Kim this is hilarious
why are you the minimalists so amazing
and offering practical and valuable
advice because we you know it's funny
man like I feel it's such an honor man
to like be able to tell our stories and
to tell our opinions and like people to
find value in them but the reason why we
have you know good advice and maybe good
opinions that people perceive and find
value in is because we've screwed up so
much in our lives
yeah and and we and III don't know about
you Josh but I do contain the errant
screw-up a lot yeah I continue to screw
up too and I like talking about those
screw-ups and helping other people learn
from them I mean when I think about my
upbringing there are there are certain
things that I will avoid altogether
because of the example that was set for
me on how not to do things essentially
I'm trying not to get too granular
because like I don't want to like you
have a temple well my parents are dead
so I can talk about right but but what
I'm saying is is like there are certain
things that I saw friends or friends of
the family or family members do and
really cause them a world of hurt and
I'm actually really grateful that I
learned those lessons with through them
instead of learning them myself there
are some lessons that you will only
learn through your own experience sadly
mm-hmm but try to learn as many lessons
from other people I mean ultimately it
has to do with a body of knowledge it
drives me crazy when I see so many 23
year olds who are becoming life coaches
most life coaches have no life
experience 37 I don't even feel
qualified to be a life coach
right yeah I feel like that's the thing
you mentor people you have this
mentoring business on our website and
you I mean yeah mentoring is different
cause like right I can speak from my own
experience and hey this is how I've done
things is how I've made things work
right it's it's a recipe but I am not
qualified to be a life coach yeah and I
think that's the thing where I see these
really like young people who aren't
living congruent with the advice they're
giving necessarily I think ultimately I
take my own advice first and then I
share that recipe with other people it's
the reason why very rarely do I talk
about my problems unless I have found
out some sort of solution although last
week on the podcast we were talking
about I had some sort of certainty head
to deal with it I don't have a solution
for that yet and so I went to a little
bit of depth on it to let people know
hey yeah I still have issues and
problems and yeah we we don't wake up
every morning manic right like we still
have to deal with stress yes we still
have to deal with emotions with with the
negative emotions it's minimalism is not
about getting rid of
those negative emotions it's about
learning how to how to live in the real
world with those emotions yeah and
they're quite often it starts with the
stuff for us because the material
possessions are physical manifestation
of what's going on inside us and so with
those things once we deal with that
external clutter we're able to start
tamping down the internal clutter the
the mental clutter of the spiritual
clutter the emotional clutter the
psychological clutter that's going on by
dealing with that external stuff because
for whatever reason as human beings
where you're so focused on the
externalities the facade the
accumulations the trophies of so-called
success that we ignore what's going on
inside us in fact I've talked to several
Buddhists about this and and some of the
the previous questions we answered here
people are you could you could maybe
replace the word happiness with
excitement how do I be excited all the
time it's sort of the same thing yeah it
is
they of all that they avoid the negative
emotions like depression and sadness
let's say say sadness but they also
avoid excitement yeah they call it the
the middle way right yes yeah yes oh no
I totally agree man it's like avoiding
both extremes like that taking that
middle way is is the best way to to
avoid like like you said with the MDMA
you have an extreme happiness you're
gonna have an extreme sadness eventually
yeah this is Matt Kearney line and one
of our favorite musicians he in song so
I'm trying to feel the highs without the
lows and like that's the problem yeah
and if you want to feel the extreme
excitement you're going to feel the
extreme downside as well and so instead
try to find that middle way and it will
certainly oscillate between happy and
sad or whatever but there are certainly
more great days for me now more
outstanding days even with all the
problems that I've had over the last
several years with my health then if I
weren't living intentionally yeah
jb asks how have you learned to sit with
discomfort after removing your pacifiers
any practical tip
or does the arrival of discomfort always
signify that you need to change
something no discomfort is often
signifies growth right in fact you want
to sit in the discomfort zone as
jonathan friends and his memoirs called
the discomfort zone and and that's the
place from which you grow is when your
because imagine if your if you were to
like rephrase this question Ryan what do
you learn from sitting and absolute
luxury and comfort
nothing nothing yeah yeah no it's
absolutely true man you've got it you've
have to make yourself a little bit
uncomfortable to grow going back to
working out working out is uncomfortable
yes like in fact yeah Sam Harris talks
about this if you imagine the pain that
you feel from working out especially
like the day after if you have a really
yeah I could look at you right out to
how you do a lot of bench press I do all
the bench but like if you have a really
like heavy chest air squat day yeah and
your legs are on fire the next day you
know squats but I still have no but I
understand
and so yes lots of squats yeah your legs
are on fire yes right imagine if you
hadn't done that you would in your and
you felt that pain you would think you
were dying yeah and and so you also the
discomfort you experience is
perspectival in a way where you realize
like I've created this this discomfort
so I can grow it's funny to men like you
think about a massage and like those
deep tissue massages after the massage
oh yeah feels so good but like during
that massage there there is this
uncomfortable downright sometimes like
painful moments roll thing oh no that's
just like that's just straight pain yeah
I've had I've had it done I'm like my
legs because I've really tight thighs
and yeah he's but uh calves and the
shins my thin my shins are especially
tight and so how paint I didn't know you
did that help but how painful was that
it's getting one to nine out of ten Wow
yeah yeah just like a constant nine wha
know goes like you have to have light
break so do do something it's like oh
like literally screaming oh my
you imagine like and that being your job
is a role for people yeah but if you're
if you're a sadist like it's the perfect
job but let me say this out there
looking for a new line of work come over
over yeah so for those you don't know
role thing is I really really really
deep tissue massage and it's painful but
I and and I mean it I couldn't walk for
two or three days straight nothing but
the relief I got for several months
after that loosening up the scar tissue
in my legs it was amazing but there were
bruises all over my shins for several
days after that dude I'll tell you me
when we were on the Kevin Rose podcast
he brought up some I don't know if he
said it on the podcast or if he was just
kind of talking about it with it's out
right now by the way so if you all want
to check it out we had we flew up to
Portland just to hang out with Kevin
Rose at his house it was it so he had
such a huge house but it was a minimal
it was still relatively man aggressively
minimalist one beautiful it's like one
of my favorite house I've ever been it
so unbelievable but I don't know if he
said this on the podcast or if when we
were just having a conversation before
we did the podcast but he he said
something along the lines of it's like
yeah I've just always been the type of
person where you know I look at
something like boredom and like it makes
me uncomfortable and then I tell myself
yeah you know what I'm gonna get
comfortable with boredom so then he
talked about how he went out of his way
to make himself bored so he could figure
out how to start to get comfortable with
being bored and and to me finding those
uncomfortable areas I actually like seek
those out I mean not you know a hundred
percent of a time 24 hours a day but
they're like that totally inspired me to
well I mean I haven't really talked
about this yet but I eventually like I
want to take by myself I want to take
like a week and I want to go to like a
container home in Montana or something
and just like I want to be as bored as I
have ever been in my life just just to
see how comfortable I can get with it
yeah and and almost like a reset to
maybe like a or maybe a silent
meditation right um I like to Dan we
could talk to Dan about it you know Dan
Harris and do something like that but
you know I think about to when we move
when we moved to Missoula
Iram
I didn't but you know I got plugged in
relatively quick it took me a couple
three months before I found a community
people and like some friends and stuff
but there was this time where it was
just you Colin and I and you know you
and Colin that being the introverts that
you are didn't want to always hang out
me being the extrovert I was always
bugging you guys to hang out but what I
realized is like okay like I want to
respect these guys you know their time I
want to respect their needs so I'm not
gonna like sit there not gonna do
everything so I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
try to do stuff by myself and I went out
like for the first time in my life when
we moved to Missoula I went to a movie
by my I started to go to movies by
myself yeah and I remember you and our
our rest in peace one of our good
friends Stan Dukes you guys always talk
oh yeah I went saw his movie and I'd ask
you guys oh well who who did you go with
I just want by myself and to me as an
extra but I'm like that is weird why
would you go to a weirdo go to the
movies I might go do that after this
podcast so so what I did is is yeah I
started to go to movies by myself I
started to put myself in this discomfort
zone so I could get used to just being
with myself being comfortable with
myself the boredom that you're the
perceived boredom and that's the thing
once you realize one of my favorite
books is The Pale King by David Foster
Wallace and it's a book about boredom it
takes place in Peoria Illinois in 1985
predominantly in the IRS office I mean
there's an entire chapter of people just
turning pages in the chapter yeah but
it's what you realize is there's also
beauty in the boredom because here the
book is written so beautifully and it's
every sentence is gorgeous and and you
realize it's a boring book but it's a
beautiful book and there's something
beautiful
within the boredom and it's the same
thing that Buddhist monks realized that
it's not actual boredom it's not boredom
doesn't exist that the there there's no
such thing as boring only boring people
yeah
and once you realize that like you can
realize you could be completely content
and satisfied just in your own mind yeah
all right
oh this is from Austin Carter I wonder
if this is our Austin is this him
he left this question shout out to
Austin he manages the the building on
which our our studio is yeah he manages
we works without the s wait I wait the
Walmarts to buy some toilet paper that's
such a Midwestern but it really is and
everything anyway yeah so anyway Austin
says why do you do what you do have you
ever doubted following the path that
you're currently on I mean it depends
what you mean but do what you do right
it's one of the in fact this is a better
way to ask this question than the way we
typically ask the question is what do
you do yeah because make you imagine how
uncomfortable you make someone though
instead of saying what do you do we say
why do you do what you do hi I'm Ryan
what do you do what you do yeah it
reminds me of the the Rob Bell parable
well it's it's I think it's a it's an
old sort of I don't know Iraqi parable
or something or Hebrew parable boule the
yeah the the the rabbis is walking to
the the gates of the Roman city and he
stopped there and the Roman guard says
who are you and what are you doing here
and the rabbi goes excuse me he says who
are you and what are you doing here
and the rabbi goes how much are they
paying you and the Roman soldier goes
hundred dollars a day he goes well I'll
pay you twice that to come to my house
every morning and ask me those same two
questions good and because we often
don't think of these like there almost
seem like remedial questions elementary
questions where where where it's like
well who are you and what what are you
doing here yeah oh my god the profundity
in that in the same thing with Austin's
question here why do you do
what you do man what do you do what we
do I am driven to create and ultimately
it's the active of creating that really
brings me joy and fulfillment and it'll
I I do what I do because it aligns with
my values
it's a beautiful accident that we reach
this path initially when I left the
corporate world I wanted to write
fiction full-time and I publish my novel
around that same time using a lot of the
writings that I wrote throughout my my
20s and that helped me pay off some debt
that I had and at the same time though
when we started the minimalists com it
was like hey this is a different vehicle
through which I can write I want to
write maybe I don't just have to write
fiction I can be creative and write
nonfiction write blog post and maybe
eventually write nonfiction books which
we did but then I realized like oh if
such is the vehicle of writing there are
other better ways to communicate with
people writing is a great way to
communicate with one set of people a
podcast is another way to communicate
with a different set of people film is
another way to communicate with other
people social media and then YouTube is
another way to communicate with people
and so ultimately I do what I do because
I enjoy the act of creating yeah I mean
for me I know this sounds like really
like lame and cliche but I just want to
save the world man I mean if I could I
would but you know I know that that's
impossible
so maybe it's about saving some people
yeah it's not I mean and it's and I
don't want to confuse that with like
making a dent in the universe okay
because that's not what I'm trying to do
as much as I am I'm driven to help
people and on a daily basis and you know
in our old corporate job that was about
10% of my my job was to help other
people maybe you know 20% but regardless
that's that's where I wanted a hundred
percent of my attention that was the
most fulfilling and rewarding part for
race so this this you know the
minimalists this just happens to be a
vehicle that I use to to really help
people and I know that's such a cliff
what's your passion I just like to help
people
but uh but it
is my passion and I have found a way to
do it so have I ever questioned the path
that I'm on man um I wish I had a sexy
answer for this no I haven't because
ultimately you know dude if if you know
that we couldn't do the podcast anymore
we couldn't sell books I couldn't do the
mentoring program you couldn't do the
writing class yeah we could yeah we
could do speaking engagement and it very
well maybe one day I mean I that's a
very I mean it's anything's possible
right but the thing is is that if that
did happen I would still I would still
be a huge supporter of minimalism I
wouldn't look at minimalism say oh well
everything got screwed up and minimalism
turns out it wasn't the answer it's like
you know when when they're when Joel
Inge was interviewing us yesterday for
The Today Show and she said you know oh
my god a toy I forgot where I was going
with that
I have like to zip my ATD self just like
totally wrecked my my my train of
thought but what was I just saying you
were talking about the the path you're
gone if minimalism all collapse she's
not that you would say well minimalism
sucks now right right exactly so man I
really fresh forget the question she was
back on it so here's here's I have a
different answer from you I yeah I
question it all the time I question the
path amount and I think it's important
for me to do so because otherwise what's
going to happen for me is I could see
myself just going down a path because
it's become second nature for me and if
I don't question it then I'm just going
with the flow
oh yeah and I've done this from time to
time where I accidentally say yes to too
many things and I've had to get really
good at saying no and the way that I do
that is by asking the question like is
this the best use of my resources and we
have the the acronym for our five most
precious resources right the steam
acronym our skills so this is the best
use of my skills right now is is this
the best use of my time that's a T is
this best use of my energy I'm putting
all my energy into this is this the best
use of that energy or could I use it
somewhere else
that's asking that question the a is the
best use of my attention I this takes
all of my attention if I want to do this
well I better
give it my all of my attention and then
my money we're paying to put this damn
podcast out there shout-out to our
patreon supporters thank you but but
we're paying to put this podcast is the
best use of my money and right now
because I I am driven to create and this
is one creative vehicle for us I look at
our creative vehicles as a tripod the
writing is first for me the podcast a
second and the video stuff is third and
those change from time to time right now
we're heavily focused on our second
documentary so that that is take that at
one point will be the top priority for
us in fact in terms of creating it's the
number-one priority for us right now but
in terms of getting out into the world
it will eventually be the top priority
so yes I'm questioning that path every
day to make sure that either you don't
need to pivot paths a little bit 5
degrees here 5 degrees there but I'm
also willing to turn around and go in
the opposite direction if necessary yeah
absolutely I do remember what I was
gonna say no I mean when it comes to
minimalism and me being a supporter or
you know propagating this message it is
beneficial to everyone jolene yesterday
what she asked was she was like do you
think minimalism is applicable to
everyone in the world and my answer is
yes absolutely everyone can afford it to
be very deliberate with their choices
and with their resources so regardless
of whether we have a podcast or whether
we have a big social media following or
whether we have a documentary this
lifestyle of living deliberately it's
it's not just good for everyone in the
world but I believe it's necessary for
everyone in the world aspect about the
population growing with the resource
these non-renewable resources dwindling
it is very important for us as as not
just you know Western society but
everyone in the world to to live
deliberately I totally agree with what
you're saying though like I it's not
that I don't it's not that I don't don't
question what the path were on meaning I
will ask myself is there a better way
for me to add value to people's lives is
there a better way for me to help people
so yeah I totally agree in that sense
like I am constantly asking that
question in fact you know we were
talking about the the the deal that we
got worked out that we're gonna be able
to talk about here at the beginning of
2019 that was one of the questions I was
asking myself like is this the best use
of our time is this the best way that we
can get get help out to other people are
add value to other people's lives and
the answer is yeah like absolutely yeah
but we had to be really deliberate about
that right and so asking those questions
is important if you want if you want
better answers then ask better questions
all right let's do one more question
here then we'll move to the lightning
round
Sophie asks how did you create your
empire what advice would you give to
someone trying to start their own
company whilst being minimal and cutting
all social media well I mean social
media doesn't it depends on what you're
trying to accomplish with social media I
was I was talking to my doctor about
this last night actually he was like I
really like what you guys do with social
media but he's like it don't you feel
like it's kind of impersonal you you
have a social media manager who manages
your social media Jessica who does a
phenomenal job and my answer to him was
no it's still us like every word that is
posted on social media is ours
we happen to have a curator and she's
literally a curator she's worked for
several art galleries like we hired a
curator to help us cure rate and
effectively communicate our so on our
social media channels but also we use
the platform's not to drive people back
to us for more revenue we find ways to
create value add value via those
platforms not to say well check out our
new supplement or here's a sponsored
post or you know click onto our website
right now in fact on Twitter we use it
only for text right we don't have any
any links we don't have any photos and
that's the best way for us to add value
to communicate with our audience there
for Instagram it's really beautiful
photographs with beautiful words
accompanying the photographs and with
Facebook it's like well here's some
articles that we find to be useful but
it's still us and so it's us sharing us
we do you and I did a Instagram video
this morning talking about the 30 day
minimalism game and you know we just
have fun with it but we add value
we don't have an expectation of well
this is going to what's the ROI on this
post going to be our expectation isn't
always to have fun either and no but but
add value yeah absolutely you know with
any entrepreneurial endeavor if you want
to be an entrepreneur
you find a way to add value to other
people's lives if you can find a way
that truly adds values to people's lives
it could be a really nice coffee mug
or it could be a book whatever it is if
people find value in it they're going to
be willing to pay you so for any
entrepreneur out there well just going
back to this answering this question
head-on how do we create this Empire I
don't have a freaking clue honestly yeah
I mean I don't even like really look at
what we have is an empire
I mean we're able to make a living off
of what we do and you know we we are
well known but there isn't a rather the
recipe that if I could you know sit here
and go back and write the recipe on how
we got from minimalism live a meaningful
life to the second documentary that we
have there's probably a recipe there but
it's not something that anyone can
really replicate they can take pieces
from it they can take ingredients from
it and make their own recipe but doing
exactly what you and I have done that is
a really bad expectation for anyone to
do but just because we didn't do that
with it wouldn't take anyone elses exact
recipe said we're gonna do that same
exact thing right because there's gonna
be a copycat right exactly so so you
know we found ways to add value to
people's lives we never put a a money
marker on I mean in fact dude we were we
were talking about opening a coffee shop
or like being baristas um it wasn't
until I got laid off and people were
like why have you written a book yet
we're like oh yeah we're the minimalist
we should write a book right I mean we
people were asking us for something so
then we wrote a book and we gave that to
them but you know when you when you are
putting a money-making driver on it that
is not nearly as important as how can I
add value to people's lives today what
can I do for someone that they're going
to be willing to support me to help them
do help people solve problems the money
will follow yeah there's a minimal
maximum for you also if I go back and
look at what we did it money was
initially not part of it at all it was
it was a creative outlet and yeah for
the first year we didn't sell anything
yeah I mean we talked about making
twenty three thousand dollars into the
at the year most I was the end of the
year because our book came out at the
end of the year
and and so that's the thing you have to
keep in mind we we just what's uh what
Gary Vee calls
punch punch or Jab Jab right hook is
that right but really he's like a fight
because then he has a book called Jab
Jab right hook he's like if I would have
been able to pick the title it would
actually been Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab
Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab right
and that's the thing like he he works
really hard on adding immense value over
and over and with no asks and eventually
the right hook is like hey I put this
book out would you be willing to support
me
yeah and it's and it's it is a symbiotic
relationship man it's not like this okay
I'm gonna lay how can I get all these
people to support me so I could do this
one big thing to make to make money as
much as it is when you were adding value
to people's lives the money follows
because when you build that relationship
with an audience or with a customer they
start to let you know more of what they
want and if you can kind of keep that
symbiotic relationship going you will
always find a way to make money from the
value that you are adding to other
people's lives because they are willing
to support you
yes shout out to our patreon supporters
thank you for these questions here we'd
love to hear what you all have to say so
if you have a comment or tip about
anything that we've talked about today
including advice for anyone who asked a
question leave us a comment over at four
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine you can also email a voice memo
right to podcast at the minimalists com
where our favorite comments and tips on
a future episode and stay tuned to the
end of this episode for this week's
listener comments and tips Ryan what
time is it it is time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media indeed we do we are at the
minimalists on Facebook and Twitter and
Instagram and during the lightning round
this where Ryan and I each do our best
to answer every question which is a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our quotes in one place
thanks to our good friend Jessica Lynn
Williams that place is minimal Maxim's
calm all right our first question is
from Cindy Cindy roe Alyssa's good man
if you came into a large amount of money
say 10 million I'm assuming she means
dollars
yes would you still need 10 million
sterling or pesos would you start change
is everything if you came into a large
amount of money say 10 million dollars
would you still be a minimalist or would
you slowly find yourself slipping back
to more bigger and better dude if
someone dropped 10 million dollars who
rory's for both of us immediately have
minimis priors if someone dropped
millions of dollars in our lap I'll be
so grateful I'd be so grateful but dude
I would I would honestly become a
philanthropist I mean I would I'd have
enough money you know the funny thing is
you're already a philanthropy I know I
know but what I guess what I'm saying is
it would enable me to be more of a
philanthropist like honestly if I had 10
million dollars I'd be having a
conversation with you about hey how can
I go around and just start building
elementary schools and in third-world
countries that really really need it
yeah yeah what's the appropriate use of
this money I'll tell you how my life
would change if someone drops it because
about 10 million dollars on me it
wouldn't there would be some ancillary
things that would shift so instead of
renting a house because I can't afford
to buy a house in Los Angeles I would
buy a house a relatively minimalist
house right and and one that was
appropriate for me and may even be in
the same building because I'm in a condo
building we rent an apartment in a condo
building and so I might just buy an
apartment there right and and what I
would realize like I would be able to
that way I'm more financially secure
right and and in in owning a property I
own a house right now in Dayton Ohio
rental property right because I could
afford to to buy that house and and so
yes would I buy my own property instead
of renting yeah but but nothing nothing
in terms of my lifestyle would change at
all it's like we're I'll we need a
studio that's twice the size Ryan what
we're gonna do the studio twice the size
is the perfect sized studio we're gonna
get more sound panels you know it's
funny dude like I'm just thinking about
any any time that I sit down and I start
to create something whatever it is it's
the driver is never oh I gotta get this
done because we got to make money
mmm if I don't get this done then we're
not gonna be able pay the bills that's
miserable man yeah dude so I would still
have the same approach I mean it would
still be it would still be creating but
but yeah I think we have millions of
dollars it would just give
the financial means to to do some better
and bigger philanthropic things so yes
we would go for better and bigger
philanthropic things yeah and so if I
have a pithy answer I think I said it
earlier but let me try to encapsulate it
into a tweet for you podcast Shawn it
would be something like monies allowed
to be a passenger in the vehicle but it
never sits in the driver's seat ooh yeah
I'll put this on the fly
nice student all right what's the next
question Ryan well I'll give you my
pithy answer go for a hot cash on when
money is the driver in your life you're
gonna have you're gonna have a really
unhappy life yeah yeah or I guess
another way is actually we'll just leave
it at that all right next question is
from Rick Rick writes in is minimalism
different in the USA versus remote
Ethiopia or remote Congo I think this is
way of asking is are poor people can
they be minimalists yeah I usually think
so you and I grew up poor but not remote
Congo poor no so grew up America poor
which is rich I mean it compared to a
lot of other third-world countries it's
not even to do with the richness
necessarily it has to do with safety at
that point like I lived in a poor
neighborhood that wasn't a dangerous
neighborhood it was it I mean it's
relatively dangerous too if you won't
look in Beverly Hills yeah but yeah yeah
but it's not like Southside Chicago or
over-the-rhine Cincinnati
well what over-the-rhine used to be not
anymore the right now is a Williamsburg
Brooklyn yeah
and so I I didn't experience war-torn
Civil War South Sudan or something like
that however let me say this I think my
answer on this has evolved a little bit
just because we've had a lot of
experiences we've gotten emails from
people who live in Afghanistan I'm not
talking about troops in Afghanistan I'm
talking about natives of Afghanistan who
will send us an email say hey you guys
are never gonna do a tour stop over here
really big fan of your blog and we could
really use your message in Afghanistan
had people from Kenya email us and say
hey really a fan of a podcast is there
any chance you're gonna come to Kenya to
to give a talk about helping
deal with consumerism over here and it's
like oh we're all we're all human in
fact
primates you go back to the the
chimpanzee studies the there's I think
it was NPR I'm not sure where but uh who
had the story about chimpanzees when
they are get bonobos I'm pretty sure
chimpanzees because they're way more
violent than bonobos bonobos just screw
each other all the time
which is that's the society we should
aspire to be like anyway I think the
chimps they're given the bananas if you
give a chimp a banana they will eat the
banana
hey thanks for the banana I'll eat the
banana right you give them enough
bananas to share with their immediate
tribe they eat a banana first and they
share the bananas with their tribe you
give them a a horde of bananas like a
mountain of bananas you a mound of
bananas Pylea yeah oh yeah whether they
will fight other chimpanzees to the
death that's crazy and I think we do
that as humans as well we where we want
to share you talked about the beginning
of episode kids want to share they want
to help but at some point there's some
switch that flips and all of a sudden we
want to hold on to our hoard we want to
protect our hoard and I think no matter
where we are we can benefit from
intentionality yeah
that's a good that's a good minimal
maximum right there maybe we'll see if
it's tweetable
yeah I mean is it different in the u.s.
than it is in remote Ethiopia I mean
lives are different in Ethiopia than in
the US so it does minimalism or whatever
ISM you want to ask I mean of course
it's gonna look a little bit different I
mean if you want to you know think about
a family who's going through this Civil
War war-torn village decluttered in
their closet is gonna be the furthest
thing from their mind you know safety is
going to be number-one priority there so
you know in these and I'm just going to
the extreme here you know in a situation
where you've got crazy violence
happening and
you know ethnic cleansing going on and
things like that
yeah it's life's gonna look a little bit
different there in general yeah
absolutely and so lights gonna be
different no matter where you are if
you're living you know we're from Dayton
Ohio and life in Dayton is different
from life in California yeah
and and the thing that I've realized
though is no matter how many resources
you have if you have the ten million
dollars from the previous question you
want to be delivered with those you and
I won the lottery we were born in
America that's like winning the lottery
guess how many lottery Wender winners
end up broke yeah and so you may have
won the the genetic lottery I know I
certainly didn't win the genetic lottery
but but you might still end up broke
with whatever lottery you won there are
other people who didn't win any kind of
lottery at all who are still able to
overcome all of that and thrive
PS Ryan I don't have one more question
for you but this week podcast Sean let's
put up the ask the minimalists anything
we did a live stream we just recorded it
was live stream number 14 we're gonna
take the audio from that and give it out
to our patreon supporters that the video
was exclusively for our patreon
supporters as well so if you want help
keep this podcast 100% advertisement
free then head on over to the
minimalists comm a slash support and
here is a snippet from this week's
private actually what I call a
postscript episode we're gonna call it
the minimalist private podcast here is a
a excerpt from this week's private
podcast
[Music]
maybe the the key here is you you have
gone through a divorce but you might
need to divorce yourself of the trauma
and the things that trigger the trial
because the trauma is on the things the
memories aren't into things but these
things are triggering the memories that
are inside you all right so let's move
on to our added value portion of the
show so Ryan and I each talk about
something that has added value to our
lives recently you know I I know you you
like country music more than I do
way more than I do I don't like country
music at all well it's just funny um
there's only a couple new artists that I
like yeah but like I like the whole like
Johnny Cash like that type of country I
like write more more Western than
country in a way well there's a you know
Kelly musgraves is right she's like a
household name these days a famous
country star don't I don't love her
music personally but her husband his
name is Rustin Kelly and his new album
just count and it's not country but it
is its singer-songwriter that is on the
it was playing in his voice he would
call it country music right and there's
something about it that we earlier in
the episode Ryan you and I were talking
about like making bad decisions because
that the what Jordan called fleeting
happiness is fleeting like we do these
things and it's almost like he talks
about pill addiction he talks about
alcohol addiction he talks about sex
addiction on this album and it is called
dying star and the album is phenomenal I
was walking around West Hollywood the
other and I couldn't go even got a
better try to go to bed around 8:00 and
I couldn't sleep so I just like 9:30 and
I just got a bed and sort of walking
around West Hollywood when was this it's
a few nights ago like Saturday night
like a weekend night yeah yeah i was
walking those Sunset Strip home like
listening to this album I don't even
know how they walking down sunset could
relax you yeah why it was I was it
wasn't about me it was what with this
music it was this weird dichotomy
because walking down the Sunset Strip
and there's this music sort of light
it's it's music about making repeated
bad decisions and your talk about
learning from other people's bad
decisions and so maybe then this
so there's a song on there called
Jericho because at the end of this
episode there's a little tiny bit of
hope at the end of this like album
filled of bad decisions and
self-inflicted despair and it's it's a
great it's a great album the music the
writing is is beautiful and the song
called Jericho is it's like a great way
to end this episode I think awesome and
I got um album recommendation there's a
band called Alkaline Trio you would not
like them Josh they are a little bit
more kind of like spill canvas I wrote
about them in my novel to spill canvas
yeah yeah they are how would you
describe their music what would you call
it
too many guitars who is the Eagles no
it's not too many guitars it's just like
fast pace like like they have this they
have very soft parts AHA but then it
gets very filled up every song yeah
exactly dude um they just came out with
an album I call it a acoustic war they
it's actually not too bad
I don't know it actually sound like yeah
um hilarious
album is called is this thing cursed uh
it's a good album I mean you have to
like that type of music yeah I don't
even know what what is that genre
alternative I guess it would just be
alternative yeah it's a weird I
alternative sort of this catch-all
phrase alternative used to be cool what
happened I don't know this is not cool
anymore yeah yeah everything you know
the word cool used to be cool and then
it was uncool now it's cool again like
kidding it's like Tommy Hilfiger alright
oh yeah right here right now let's talk
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalist Ryan what we just did the
Today Show interview I that might even
be out by the time this episode comes
out if so we'll put a link to it the
show notes
if not then we won't what else is going
on in our lives you're getting ready to
travel
yeah heading to Montana today actually
right out of those days I can hang out
with some family um man you know we
can't really talk about the project that
we just the big project that we just
signed yeah let's call distilled project
Z we call it nice nice I don't know man
what else is going on dude that's it I
think
I'll leave here today with one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time
hi my name is Carrie Jo Crandall I'm
calling from Kansas City Missouri my
comment is for Timothy
from the sponsors episode I found
minimalism about six years ago and my
husband wasn't on board but I slowly
started moving my things around getting
rid of things in excess clutter in my
life
to where he saw that I was becoming a
happier person and once I got rid of my
things he started picking up on things
that he could declutter in his life and
through conversations gentle
conversations with each other we were
able to convince down pretty much
everything that we had we had lots of
conversation
lots of frustrations but more good
conversations through getting rid of the
things that I have and I will we started
working together as a team it's when we
really started seeing how awesome
minimalism was for our marriage so I
just encourage you to just slowly slowly
start moving your things around to where
she can see that by you getting rid of
things that were access to you she will
notice that you are now happier and that
maybe she will want to jump on board to
be with you so that you can be happier
together hey this is Jesse from Kansas
City and I just have a quick tip that's
sort of a technical version of a packing
party I had too many apps on my phone I
know a lot of us have that same issue so
what I did is I deleted every single one
that the operating system would allow me
to and then I would just read download
it as soon as I needed it I would just
keep those ones that I needed
hi minimalist this is Emma calling from
Mammoth Lakes California just a tip for
people with gift-giving in my family we
have a very large family and what we've
decided to do recently is draw names so
at Thanksgiving we all pick a name and
we receive one name for a family member
and we exclude some people mom and dad
we always can get them gifts but as for
the sibling we each pick another
siblings name and that way we're in
charge of only that person's gift and
this just makes it easier because we're
able to spend a little more money on
something that might bring them a little
more value or maybe be a more exciting
experience for them something they will
really appreciate more than just going
and buying someone a pair of socks for
their stocking and minimus --tz--